tu es une personne grossière et terrible c'est
assez posé le micro c'est
assez  que
cette caravane était une invasion, comme vous le savez,
je la considère comme de nombreux
présidents.
merci pour le bronzage
pourquoi avez-vous pourquoi l'avez-vous caractérisé
comme tel que je considérais une invasion vous
et j'ai une divergence d'opinion
pensez-vous que vous avez diabolisé les immigrants
non pas comme une conférence je les veux je veux qu'ils
viennent dans le pays mais  ils
doivent entrer Légalement, vous savez qu'ils doivent
venir et passer par un processus Je veux que ce
soit un processus et je veux que les gens
entrent et nous avons besoin des gens votre
avion vous attendez vous savez pourquoi nous avons besoin
du papier que vous parce que  nous avons
des centaines d'entreprises qui emménagent nous avons besoin
des gens votre campagne avait une publicité
montrant des migrants escaladant les murs et
donc c'est pour ça mais ils n'ont pas agi
ils ne vont pas faire ils n'étaient pas
actrice quoi non c'est vrai n'est-ce pas
pense qu'ils étaient des acteurs ils étaient
une actrice ils ne venaient pas d'
Hollywood c'étaient des gens c'était
un vrai vous savez c'est arrivé il y a
quelques jours et ils sont à des centaines de
kilomètres bien qu'ils soient à des centaines et des
centaines de kilomètres  que ce n'est pas une
évasion honnêtement, je pense que vous devriez
me laisser diriger le pays, vous dirigez CNN ou et si
vous l'avez bien fait, vos notes, laissez-moi vous demander si vous êtes
inquiet, c'est assez
président a demandé à l'une des autres personnes
qui ont dit maintenant pardonnez-moi ma '  suis
M.  président ça suffit ce
président j'en ai eu un que vous savez que je
peux poser sur l'enquête sur la Russie
craignez-vous que vous ne vous soyez peut-être
préoccupé de quoi que ce soit avec vous ne
pouvez pas signer l'enquête parce que
c'est un canular êtes-vous assez
posé le  micro m.  président êtes-vous
inquiet des actes d'accusation à venir dans
cette enquête
mr.  président je vais vous dire ce que CNN
devrait avoir honte de vous faire
travailler pour eux vous êtes une personne grossière et terrible
vous ne devriez pas travailler pour CNN
allez-y je pense que c'est sur vous êtes une
personne très grossière la façon dont vous traitez Sarah
Huckabee est horrible et la façon dont vous
traitez les autres est horrible, vous
ne devriez pas traiter les gens de cette façon pour
la défense de Jim J'ai voyagé avec lui et je
l'ai regardé c'est un journaliste diligent qui
s'affaire Je ne suis pas un grand fan de vous non plus
alors  Je comprends pour être honnête, alors
laissez-moi vous poser une question si je peux vous
amuser à plusieurs reprises, vous êtes le meilleur
mr.  président vous à plusieurs reprises au
cours de juste asseyez-vous s'il vous plaît
bien quand vous rapportez de fausses nouvelles
non quand vous rapportez de fausses nouvelles que CNN
fait beaucoup vous êtes l'ennemi du
peuple allez-y me manque
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
M.  vie personnelle allez-y personnellement
puisque vous assistez à notre
agence de presse, ne pouvez-vous pas nous donner une
chance, je vais dire que vous frappez,
vous êtes de faux droits
[Musique]